6-Nuit English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6-minute English from BBCLearningEnglish. I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth.
Head over heels, butterflies in the tummy, the apple of my eye.
In English, there are many idioms to describe what it feels like to fall in love.
Ah, I didn't know you were such a romantic, Neil.
But do you know what's actually happening in our brains when we fall in love?
Because I'm sorry to say this, Neil, but it's more about brain chemistry than romance.
Specifically hormones, chemical messengers which the body releases into the blood to control our
growth, mood, and yes, falling in love.
Thanks for ruining my romantic ideas, Beth.
And since my dreams are now shattered, why don't we spend the rest of this program
finding out exactly what is going on inside our bodies and brains when we fall in love?
And of course, learn some useful new vocabulary too.
There's no doubt that being in love has the health benefit of reducing stress,
even lengthening your life. But the hormones which the brain releases have an immediate effect as well.
So, chemically speaking, what happens when lovers look into each other's eyes?
Is it A, their body temperature increases,
B, their heartbeat harmonise, or C, the hairs stand up on the back of their neck?
Is it all three? No, okay then. I'll guess it's B, their heartbeat harmonise.
Okay, we'll find out if that's correct at the end of the program.
According to Helen E. Fisher, self-help author and anthropologist at Rutgers University,
there are three aspects of romantic love. Here's BBC Ideas to explain more.
Often loss comes first, but not always. For some people who are asexual, it may not happen at all.
But for those who do experience lust, it's driven by the hormones, estrogen and testosterone.
It may feel purely carnal, but in fact, it's about the urge to mate and pass on your DNA via offspring.
Without lust, it's fair to say our species would not survive.
Helen E. Fisher thinks the first aspect of love is purely physical, lust, the strong feeling of
sexual desire for someone. Lust is driven by the hormones estrogen in women and testosterone in men.
A few people are asexual, meaning they don't feel sexual attraction for anyone of any gender.
Lust is hardwired into us through our DNA and it drives us to have children.
Helen thinks it's fair to say that without lust, our species would not survive.
Here she uses the phrase it's fair to say to introduce an idea she believes to be true and reasonable.
Of course, love is not just physical. Here's BBC Ideas again to introduce Helen Fisher's second aspect of love attraction.
The second aspect of romantic love is attraction, influenced by a neurotransmitter called dopamine.
This is a feel good substance released in our brain that is involved in driving us towards reward.
Do something, get a dopamine hit, feel good. Eventually dopamine will push us towards
repeating that behavior. This is why intense attraction feels like an addiction to another
human being. Some people get stuck in that loop, always chasing the dopamine-soaked excitement of
a new relationship. This time, the hormone responsible is dopamine, a neurotransmitter that rewards
our attraction to someone with pleasurable feelings. That's why dopamine is called a feel good
substance. The adjective feel good can be used to describe anything causing happy and optimistic
feelings about life, things like feel good films or feel good music. Here though, there's a downside.
The dopamine hit of sexual attraction feels so good, we crave it more and more.
Some people are always chasing the next relationship to get a new hit of pleasure and soon become
stuck in a loop. An idea meaning they're unable to break the habit of repeating the same
patterns of behavior over and over again. It's fascinating to see the power which hormones have over us,
but if you're an old-fashioned romantic, like Neil, don't despair. And speaking as a romantic,
how about the answer to my question? Right, you asked me about the effect on the body when two
lovers look deep into each other's eyes. I guess it was that their heart beats harmonize.
Which was the correct answer. In experiments, looking into the eyes produced hormones,
causing couples hearts to beat in time. Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned in this
programme, starting with the idiom head over heels, to be completely in love with someone.
Last is a very strong feeling of sexual desire. Someone who is asexual does not feel sexual
attraction towards anyone of any gender. The phrase it's fair to say is used to introduce a
statement you believe to be true and reasonable. The adjective feel good describes something which
makes people feel happy and optimistic. And finally, the idiom stuck in a loop describes
someone unable to break the habit of repeating the same negative patterns of behavior over and over
again. Once again, our six minutes are up, but remember to join us again next time for more
topical discussion and useful vocabulary here at 6 Minute English. Goodbye for now. Bye!